foreign
[Music]
this is Star Talk and right now we're
slipping in an explainer these have
become a very popular format of our
offerings and we take some topic that's
in the news or not and just tell you the
latest on it and what's going down and
what's going up I got with me Paul
Mercurio Paul welcome back again yeah
thanks great to meet you all right dude
you're still hanging out with Stephen
Colbert as one of his stable of
comedians is that right yeah yeah you
know somebody's got to carry him you
know
don't tell the boss they said that okay
of course not okay
that's our secret and every listener
here we'll all keep that in secret
absolutely you're due to be back on the
show you haven't been on in a while you
haven't been in a while that's all right
that's all right and you uh and you've
got your own podcast inside out with
Paul mccarrio and you've been on it
you've been great yeah thanks for having
me thanks for having me well you know
what we're talking about today okay
there's the juice Mission Jupiter icy
moons Explorer that's a great name
because it tells the alien forms that
we're like rock and vitamin C and we're
not going to be truthful okay
okay now I know a little bit about it
but I don't have the straight up
expertise necessary to Cloud to qualify
for an explainer installment we've got
our friend of Star Talk Kevin hand on
hand Kevin welcome back to start talk
hey Neil uh great to see you again hi
Paul uh
all right you're an astrobiologist and a
planetary scientist at the jet
propulsion labs in Pasadena California
show off
wait wait you haven't heard nothing yet
uh author of alien oceans the search for
life in the depths of space love it love
it you direct the ocean worlds Lab at
JPL and your co-investigator of the
Europa Clipper and the dragonfly Titan
missions and you were also scientists
with the Mars perseverance Mission so
you the man
there's a lot of it it's a it's a it's
an incredible thing we no longer have
time for the segment just because of
your insurance
yes so so give me give us all like we
read the headlines about this mission
that was recently launched but why don't
you give us the highlights of what
you're looking for and why and how come
this Mission wasn't flown decades ago oh
goodness yeah
um so the first uh big picture thing
with with juice uh is that it's
incredibly exciting from the standpoint
of it is one of a pair of twin
spacecraft juice is the European space
agencies spacecraft heading out to
Jupiter to study the moons of Jupiter
and Jupiter itself
and then on the NASA side in about a
year and a half October 2024 knock on
wood
we'll send the Europa Clipper Mission
out to the Jovian system to study Europa
directly and while there are many
different things that we're excited
about for me personally uh it boils down
to one word and that is Oceans oceans
oceans
we have good evidence that worlds like
Europa and Ganymede and potentially
Callisto three of the large moons of
Jupiter have liquid water oceans beneath
their icy shells and if we've learned
anything from life on Earth it's at
where you find the liquid water you
almost always find life that's been a
mantra of NASA follow the water right
there exactly we're starting to get it
done we're we're getting out there
you're figuring out and so why why is
this the first time we're sending probes
I mean we've known about it all right
ever since probably the early early
Voyager missions so why did it take so
long yeah I'm Neil as you know this this
business is not for the faint of heart
when I was an undergrad many moons ago
uh there was a NASA graphic showing a
melt probe going through on Europa and
the date on that mission was 2009.
well 2009 has come and gone and we don't
have a melt probe but at least we have
these two missions heading out there to
fly by these moons and give us
incredible remote sensing data and
observations of the surfaces of both
Ganymede and Callisto which you're
saying they're things you go in there
but you're not going to land on either
of those missions
correct come on I know
I mean I could run this Mission you guys
guys don't make me cry I don't know
listen are you working three days are
you working three day weeks is that the
problem just just deploy Paul he'll have
an ax pick he'll get through it just
fine listen I just want to know if we're
going to find 7-Elevens on other Earths
because on other other planets because
they're doing really well for us here
people
listen they're your sign of life big
gulps and spinning hot dogs it's doing
well for us here if we can find it
well we'll mark that down as a
biosignature 7-Eleven what what kind of
biosignature can you expect if there's
life in the Under Ice Water that's not
otherwise
um reaching the Detectors of your flyby
missions yeah yeah so it's a great
question and the the goal of both the
juice Mission and eventually the Europa
Clipper mission is to assess the
habitability of these worlds and Juice
specifically will fly by Europa it'll
fly by Callisto but then it will go into
orbit around Ganymede and Ganymede is
the largest moon in our solar system uh
it's bigger even than Mercury
and it's got all sorts of curious things
along with the ocean it's good it's
bigger than planet Mercury right that's
right exactly yeah okay that's right and
uh it's got its own magnetic field we
don't understand why
um and as I mentioned it likely has this
salty liquid water ocean
who knows it could have life
um but Gana meets Ice shell is quite
thick
in the case of Europa and I think I mean
about now let's call it 100 kilometers
give or take 50. I would call that thick
yes okay yes
the men in europa's case we're talking
about an ice shell of a few to perhaps
20 kilometers a day now that still
sounds thick and but by comparison the
thickest part of the Antarctic sheet is
about four kilometers so Europa may have
an ice shell as thin as Antarctica size
sheet
and why that's important is because at
least for now with these spacecraft that
will fly by uh Europa and juice which
will orbit Ganymede the ice shells serve
as a window into the ocean below and so
we hope that by studying the surface
chemistry with various spectrometers we
can figure out if we're seeing ocean
chemistry coming up onto that ice
and possibly things like carbon
compounds Organics things that might be
hints of a habitable ocean beneath the
ice okay so you're saying because the
ice I'm saying like the obvious now in
retrospect because the ice is a frozen
variant of the water that's below it if
you study the ice you'll get some
indication of what might be below it is
that a fair exactly it's certainly for
the case of Europa the ice shell serves
as a lens into the ocean below for
Ganymede it's still a bit of a question
mark but we do think we're seeing salts
on the surface of Ganymede also and
salts would be indicative of Ocean
material coming up to the surface our
thermal Pockets key to this too within
once you're below the ice and that's
where the feeling is that that this life
form can really exist yeah yeah yeah
you're not supposed to stump the guest
no right you know what I think I'm done
here
doing Drop the earbuds here we go
well done Paul well done yeah so so
Kevin we've seen the pictures of geysers
and sort of pressure forced flows coming
from beneath ice maybe not on Ganymede
or but we've seen them on these moons so
is there localized sources of heat or is
this a general warming from the tidal
forces that we've read about yeah so the
straight up answer is we don't know
um but in the case of Europa we do have
good evidence of a lot of fracturing
happening on its surface that could be
from the tidal flexing of the ice shell
do I just to be clear this is not
fracking this is fracturing
please don't start picketing there we go
no you want more more money for it to
drill for a drill baby drills that that
part would be nice but the um yeah
Jupiter is 318 times as massive as the
Earth and so when you think about the
tidal energy that that we experience
just looking at the ocean tides here on
Earth going in and out and now magnify
that and think about what it would be
like to be on Europa orbiting Jupiter
there's just a tremendous amount of
tidal energy getting pumped into Europa
and that could generate uh cause these
fat fractures that could generate
hydrothermal vents on the sea floor it
could generate Blooms of oceanic
material erupting through the ice and
out onto the surface we just don't know
but hopefully with these spacecraft that
are being launched juice just launched
and Clipper will be launched soon
hopefully these spacecraft will be able
to uh to give us some some data that'll
help us nail this down okay so now let's
say you get some data and you say oh
there's some Organics let's go back and
now dig so are you going to melt through
10 15 kilometers of ice or you have some
other clever way to do that
are you going to launch uh Bruce Willis
onto a craft that's going to land with a
laser
a nuke he's got to drill the hole for
the nuke I'm telling you guys this
is okay it's gonna directed by Mike hey
Dwayne Johnson is going to be the lead
wait there is a movie called The Europa
Report oh there it is yeah which which I
have a cameo in I don't want to brag
yeah okay I think I was overlooked by
the academy that year maybe I voted for
you so what does the mechanism to
actually do the drilling
well we've got a few different
mechanisms but before we landed a a
drill or melt Probe on the surface we
would have to send a Lander down so
search for uh for biosignatures to
search for signs of life and I think
with a landed mission that did that we
would then have the kind of the the the
confidence to move forward with a truly
ambitious mission of getting through the
ice and and the initial Lander would
also give us the the necessary
measurements of the ice thickness and
what we call the regolith properties
kind of the the physics and chemistry of
the ice and what it would take to drill
or melt through it are people still
thinking about melting through
oh yeah absolutely and okay so so last I
read you're gonna melt with some kind of
radioactive normal generating ball that
drop two is that correct right so so you
could use uh what's called an RTG uh uh
to melt through or you could use a
mechanical drill uh we just don't know
enough about the fire starter that you
get at Ace Hardware for 2.99 just if you
just do that enough that's okay
Paul you gotta go you gotta join NASA
it's very clear but wait wait Kevin in
just the couple of minutes we have left
uh I know NASA has an office of
planetary protection that worries about
forward contamination of our germs or
anything else that or back contamination
to Earth if we have sample returns if
you're going to melt through ice with a
radioactive object won't that disrupt or
interfere with any life that might be
there and possibly create Godzilla
because last I checked we got Godzilla
because of radioactivity from Fallout
from nuclear Wars last I checked right
and and that's certainly a tremendously
important consideration that we factor
into all of our missions that look for
signs of life beyond Earth because we
want to protect Europa for the Europeans
we want to protect Mars for the Martians
and that's why in one of the the key
initial designs for landing on Europa
there is no uh radioisotope source it
was just based on primary batteries it
simplified a lot of those concerns about
bringing little Earth hitchhikers that
could
contaminate the ocean okay you I heard
Jupiter has a lot of radiation on its
own in a bombarded Europa it seems
counterintuitive to me how does how does
life exist when being bombarded by
radiation Europa good one yeah well yeah
and this is this is right uh this is
right with exactly what I do in my lab
Etc Europa gets bombarded by all these
electrons and ions from Jupiter's
magnetic field the ice on Europa
protects anything in the ocean below but
there's this really cool thing that
happened so right now as you're
breathing Earth's atmosphere what is
what's the most important compound that
you're breathing in for the sake of your
energy I'm thinking oxygen yeah right
exactly so we need oxygen anything large
on Earth any macro organism requires
oxygen microbes can get by on other
stuff on Europa the radiation
environment from Jupiter bombards the
ice splits apart some of the H2O some of
that recombines into oxygen and if some
of that oxygen in the ice of Europa gets
transported to the ocean below
then who knows maybe uh europa's ocean
has enough oxygen to support not just
microbes but also fish or european squid
or that Godzilla
Godzilla a squid versus Godzilla that's
good that's the movie I'll pay today
yeah we'll fund our missions that way
and just to be clear Kevin you said you
break apart the hydrogen and oxygen in
the water and then the oxygen recombines
with itself you mean right because if
you bring about water it's just H2O
there's only one oxygen sitting there
and actually is going to find another
one to get O2 because that's what we
breathe is O2 molecule right okay yeah
just clever so how soon last question
here how soon can we how long does it
take to get there and when we're going
to have our first data yeah so data from
juice and the Europa Clipper Mission
will come back in about the 20 30 31
time frame is when we'll enter the
Jovian system and so the early 2030s
we'll start getting pictures back
um and then uh who knows what happens
after those don't you think at that
point people are going to be like oh
this is so eight years ago
Jupiter blah blah blah no no so Paul
though there's a rule an Unwritten rule
never engage in an experiment if you
don't live long enough to see results so
you can so so Kevin I think he's got
another eight years in him we're hoping
for yeah we're bucking for you Kevin
yeah oh thanks I'm hoping I can live
long enough until we get that Lander out
there as well I need a little more fruit
but otherwise you look good you'll be
okay yeah well I love what you do Kevin
and I have this fantasy that we're gonna
take Star Talk on the road that will do
a little sort of recording from your lab
and just you can show us what you do
yeah and so what kind of creatures
you're creating in your in your oceans
excellent okay I could use more help in
the lab we can get you doing an
experiment and not irradiating some
stuff cool cool and bring Paul because
he'll have some great questions there
I'll try listen I'll be two he knew
exactly I studied for weeks for this
thank God I remembered them all right we
got to wrap it there uh Kevin always
great to have you here as you're our
window into all that matters as we ex as
we continue to turn the solar system
into our backyard so staying Arms Reach
of us will come back to you Paul I know
you got to run uh Stephen Colbert's
waiting for his next joke
yes very interesting stuff Kevin and uh
I gotta go fight Godzilla now so uh
there you go all right all right this
has been start talk another explainer
Edition this one on the juice Mission
and the uh Clipper what's the full name
of the NASA version Europa Clipper
Europa Clipper juice from the European
space agency and the Europa Clipper from
NASA Neil deGrasse Tyson you're a
personal astrophysicist here okay keep
looking up
thank you
foreign